[موسيقى]
السلام
عليكم
طبعا انسب وقت ان انا اطلع فيه على المسرح
بعد اللي سمعناه عن التراث والاغاني
والحاجات الشعبيه دي انا مش عارف انا
هتكلم ازاي بس يعني ربنا
يستر لو هتكلم في الاول هقول انا تايه على
باب الله متغرب الله الله ولا ليا سلطان
ولا جاه ولا ليا في التوه دليل انا تايه
يا اد النيل متغرب وبلادي سبيل فاتحه لكل
بنات الليل جفله في وشي يا حول الله انا
تايه على باب
الله اول
لقانه حضن اللي راجعين من السفر على قد ما
الشوق هدهم كان اللقى يا بنا يا حته من
الجنه انا شايفك تفاح لبنان وشفايفك قشر
الرمان محبوبه يا ام الفستان انا عاشق
وعيوني دليل فضحوني غنيت عريان قفشوني
جابه السلطان كتفني بفيونكه ستان على بابك
زي المساطيل انا عارفك من قبل ما اشوفك
انا حافظك من قبل ما اصم وحروفي بتدوب في
حروفك وكفوف في على طول بتضم غنيتك ومانيش
كروان حبيتك من اول لمحه ضميتك والكون
غيران ولقيتك راضيه ومسامحه لحونا عفاريت
ملجان حسدونا فقريه قران من حسن كتاب
الشيطان بكى ادم نوله المنديل مش عودك
العود ده كمان وخدودك ريشه والوان انفاسك
اجمل برفان بيصحي اجدعها قتيل راح اطولك
لو فيها لمان واتعلم عشق التفاصيل شعرك
شعرك تسابيح سبتي لي الريح اصبح اذكار
والصبح جريح عمال بيصيح على سقف الدار انا
حي في حي ملي الكفار الله الله الله امام
بيسبح فوق خصلات شعرك 99 ويتم ال 100 على
خدك بيفصل ملكوت في خياله ويطلع بالملي
على قدك الليل ملاك نازل عليه بالوحي
والوحي شعر والشعر في وجودك يربط حزام
للشمس ترقص على عودك بين الشجر والحجر
تهنى ولا عارفين احنا اللي كنا الحجر ولا
الحجر احنا يخضر ورق الشجر تتبل ملامحنا
اول طلب بطلبه ساعه ما احضر جن اديكي من
عمري وما تكب بريش في السن انا وانت دنيا
ودين حبه قصايد قصايد ماشيين على رجلين
بتحسدنا الشوارع بالتراب ويحسدنا التراب
بالعين لو نشتري بعضنا بتعيط الفترين
رقيتك بالغنى مرات وبضحكه سبع مرات رقيتك
من ود وبنات من الحساد وم الشياطين حصوه
في عيون الولي يال انت عشقك ورد حصوه في
عيون البشر حصوه في عيون القرد حصوه في
عيون نورهم حصوه في عيون ليلهم حصوه في
عيون الناس وعيوني اولهم يالي انت نعمه
ربنا انت البريئه الفاتنه والمستحيله
الممكنه من نسل ادم زينا ولا انت مين حور
قلب اتخلق من نور يا واضعي الدستور حبي
مالوش قوانين في العشق لو مجاذيب فانا اول
المجانين ابين زين ابين زين واغن نيلك
بدال الغنوه غنوتين وارقص بيكي واصلي ولو
زغلل عينيك الشمس اضمك تمشي في
ضني مسارح
وسيمه وسيرك وقفيش مسارح وسيمه وسيرك
وقفيش وصوره المنيل وكاب ش وكلب الحراسه
وكرسي الرئاسه وحبه سياسه وتربه حشيش تدخن
يا فندي سجاير بلاش وتنسى اللي ميت وتنسى
اللي عاش وتخلع هدومك وتلبس همومك وتاكل
سمومك وتحبس بشاش تكيه بهيه وكشك السعاده
ودمك يا حلوه يا سكر زياده وسرخ بناتك
وشرخه نياتك شهاده وفاتك في حاله عباده
تكيه بهيه وكشك السعاده تذاكر يا هانم
تذاكر يا بيه هتدخل بعيل تحاسب عليه جميع
اللي ماتوا عيالي الصغار جميع اللي عاشوا
ملوك القمار جميع اللي خانوا وقالوا في
ودانه يبين سنانه ويعيش الحمار يا سارح
بطبله يا ماسك دفوف مسير اللي اعمى هيرجع
يشوف ويلعن ابوكم وام الظروف ويرفع سيوفه
في وش الطار مسارح وسيمه وسرك وقفيش
سيناريو العجايب عجيب العجاب تموت البراءه
وتحيا الكلاب تصنع مهازل تهدم منازل تشيد
عوازل ما بين الصحاب اتاري اللي ميت اتيل
الغرام وتاري البلد دي بتهل كلام وتهوى
البنادق وتهوى الخنادق وتهوى اللي صادق في
صوره عضام عزيزي المواطن عزيزي الفقير
امالك في بكره بتنقص كتير بتنقص بلادك
اراضي وبيوت
وتنقص ولادك تابوت فوق تابوت فقفل بيوتك
وامن تابوتك وخطط لموتك وجرب تموت حياتك
يا فندي حياه ما تساويش فايه اللي يكبر
جنابك تعيش وبين الشوارع وبين الحارات
وبين الجوامع وبين البارات وبين اللي عايش
وبين اللي مات حواجز وشيش خلف شيش خلف شيش
مسارح وسيمه وسرك
وقفيش
شكرا
نهرب من
مين نهرب من مين وفي كل محطه نلاقي كمين
وشويش وامين اصبحنا بواقي بني ادمين بنخاف
نسجد ونخاف نركع اللي تحول مستنقع كلنا
مرضى وبنفض نرفض فبنى جربنا الفوضى يا
حلواني لفينا قد ما لفينا ورجعنا ل طوعك
من تاني احكي لي حكايه عن الوادي ما بلاها
لا تموت متحسر شفت الكوابيس والشيخ قال لي
اياك تحكيها لا تتفسر لكن هحكي لك وكاني
مرغم مضطر لو نقدر نمشي على الميه هنسيب
البر خير النمل ماشي بالطيره العفره خير
هو اللي كافر ولا البلد كافره طلع النهار
يضحك من ضحكته الصفرا النمل مات طاير من
الحلم قبل الشقه غضبت عليه السما صبح
السحاب مشنقه خير النمل ماشي بطيروا
العفره خير هو اللي كافر ولا البلد كافره
طلع النهار يضحك من ضحكته الصفرا النمل
مات طاير من الحلم قبل الشقه غضبت عليه
السما صبح السحاب مشناه احكي لي عن احوال
الارض احكي لي عن احوال الارض اعراض تلفا
قلوب عريانه وبرق ورعد الناس ببساطه بكل
بساطه بتاكل بعض خير ما بقاش فيه خير
القلب كفيف والباب مفتوح يكفينا شر العمى
لما يصيب الروح لما العيال في المدرسه
تضحك تضحك بكاها يزيد واما العيال في
المدرسه تبكي بيغيروا الاناشيد الواحد
واقف مصلوب والاثنين تحديف الطوب والثلاثه
رصاصه تفوت والاربعه الناس بتموت الخمسه
تجار الدين والسته كلاب السلاطين والسبعه
اطياف النور والثمانيه النار والسور
والتسعه صوت الحرافيش والعشره يا نموت يا
نعيش وترجع سندريلا النيل وترجع فرحه
الايتام وطهر القاهره بالليل وضحكه سمعه
في الافلام اللهم اني اسالك يا عاطي يا
وهاب لو مت اموت جوه وبلاش اموت على الباب
وبلاش اكون واحد من الف فاتهم قطر يا رب
اكون نكته ويكون ده اخر
سطر اس البنات يا مطر وهيط حوا اللولي لا
تموت حاجات يا مطر ويعجز الخولي يسق
البنات يا مطر وهيط حوا اللولي لا تموت
حاجات يا مطر ويعج زل خولي يا جنيني لازما
تعود يا جنيني تسق الورود يا جنيني وترمي
ضحكك مع التقاوي تحصد غناوي يا جنيني يا
عقد فلي يا ورد قو لي انا ليه تملي عطشان
غنايا وليه الجنايني كل اما اغني بيسد عني
مي القنايه وليه القنايه بتبخ نوح وليه
غنايه ما فيهش روح وليه حبيبتي ما تسقني
وليه هموت طب ليه بعيش وليه السما مخلوقه
فوق وليه الاراضي حديد وطوق طب امتى المحن
الشروق ونهارنا يطلع يا جنيني يا جنيني
ادي البنات يا جنيني سكر نبات يا جنيني
وادي العيال فرح ومراجيح للدنيا باب
والباب مقفول وحياه ولادك يا جنيني هات
المفاتيح عايزين تاني
طيب هختم بس بحاجه كده طويله شويه
ومختلفه الوصايا
العش من شبه
ميت للي يهمه الامر ما تقولش مات الولد
وهو غمض شاف قول لما ماتت ولد كان التراب
شفاف والدنيا بنت صغيره لكننا عواجيز
الموت يجوز طيب لكن مالهش عزيز ما تقولش
لامي اني مع
الاموات امي دي لو تبكي
هتزللك خلي الملائكه يبلغوه بلين وبدال ما
تبكي دموع تضحك فتحي الطين بلغ سلامي
للغريب القريب والقريب الغريب واليمام
والحمام
والهيمنه والعشمانين في الزحام وان يسالوك
عني قول لهم سافر سافر بعود مشدود واقف
على حيله الغربه مسكت عود غنت ترا تيله
ماتتعشمش نتقابل يجوز الجنه ماتسعناش
يجوز كفه ميزان اعمالنا ما تطب يجوز بنحب
في الجنه يجوز الجنه ما تحبش ما تتع الشمش
نتقابل حاجات ياما ما تضمنها
قلوبنا لو تموت ساعتها النار ما تلسعها
زرع اليتيم كلما بيشوف السماء بيخاف وهو
اللي كان بيملي للشمس النهار فتصدر للخل
الارض الارض امه اللي ماتت وهي فيه في
الطلق وم نزلتش دموع من يوم ما فاته ابوه
زرع اليتيم يا رفاق ما تبطلو تسقوه عطشان
يا ورد عطشان يا ورد اشرب رد بوجع لا ظهر
البنفسج مات من حزنه على السقه انا
والحمام والبرج من فتره كنا اصحاب لو حد
فينا كان كلنا نتصاب فرق ما بينا الزمن
ومسبب الاسباب طرحت قلوبنا اسات وتفرط
البلاب ارضى بحكم القدر ارضى بحكم القدر
نارك تصير
واحد هينز في دم التاني
يتحنى اصلب على قبري كل اللي عدوا على
السطور ضحكوا وبلاش تطبطب على البنات
بالحرف معظم بنات حوا اضعف من الكلمه لو
ناوي تمشي صحيح سيب للبنات ذكرى غير
الجراح في القلب لو صعب تفضل وفي يبقى
اشتري لهم كلب الشعر الشعر قلب اخضر راديو
بلا تشويش واللي يقول الشعر يلقى الدهب في
الخيش اياك اياك تكون مهنه وفر فتاوي
الشيوخ ما اغنى الشعر فتوى وما كسب كلنا
في الاساس فاسدين رغم اختلاف النسب ما
تولوش الشعر للارقام وما تسالوش الشعر ليه
وبكام الشعر دنيا للي عايش فيه الشعر حلم
المدمنين
احلام الوصيه الاخيره ليها وللناس انا
اضعف من ورق التوت فبلاش تظنوا في الفراق
السوق كل الحكايه اني تعبت هنا فطلعت اجرب
في الحياه من فوق ادعوي بالرحمه ادعولي
بالرحمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرا
n